From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. For months, people were afraid. The virus outbreak started out small, but then grew exponentially. Within days, every part of the country, every part of the world was affected. Uncertainty and confusion abounded. Miss Judgements about how to fight the pandemic proved catastrophic. All this rings true today, but it was also true a century ago. Almost exactly 100 years ago, a new infectious disease swept the world. My guess this week says the lessons from that outbreak are instructive if we only stop to listen.
来自NPR，这里是隐形大脑，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。几个月来，人们一直感到恐惧。病毒疫情最初规模很小，但随后呈指数级增长。几天之内，全国各地、世界各地都受到了影响。不确定性和混乱随处可见。关于如何应对大流行的错误判断被证明是灾难性的。这一切在今天听起来依然真实，但在一个世纪前也是如此。几乎恰好在100年前，一种新的传染病席卷了全球。我本周的猜测表明，只要我们停下来倾听，那次疫情给我们的教训是具有启示意义的。
Nancy Bristow is a historian at the University of Puget Sound. She is the author of American Pandemic, the Lost Worlds of the 1918 Influenza Epidemic. Nancy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. Give me a sense of the scale of the 1918 pandemic Nancy. This was a massive event. Inside the United States, more than a quarter of Americans were second. By the time the pandemic was through 675,000 Americans would die. And the estimates vary for the world for somewhere between 50 and 100 million people. And a third of people on the globe were likely infected.
南希·布里斯特罗是普吉特海湾大学的历史学家。她是《美国大流行：1918年流感大流行的失落世界》一书的作者。南希，非常感谢你今天来到“隐形大脑”。非常感谢。南希，能让我大致了解一下1918年大流行的规模吗？这是一场巨大的事件。在美国国内，超过四分之一的美国人感染了。当大流行结束时，将有67.5万名美国人死亡。对于全球死亡人数的估计各不相同，大约在5000万到1亿人之间。而且全球有三分之一的人可能被感染。
So this was not the first time the country had been affected by an influenza outbreak. and a third of people on the globe were likely infected. So this was not the first time the country had been affected by an influenza outbreak. What is it that made this strain so dangerous, Nancy? The influenza virus is a very clever virus. It's constantly changing, drifting through limited but frequent changes in its genetic makeup during the reproduction process. But sometimes there's a thing called antigenic shift. It's a much more dramatic transformation
所以这并不是该国第一次受到流感疫情的影响。而且全球有三分之一的人可能被感染。所以这并不是该国第一次传播流感疫情。南希，到底是什么让这种病毒株如此危险？流感病毒是一种非常聪明的病毒。它在不断变化，在繁殖过程中通过对其基因构成的有限但频繁的变化进行漂移。但有时会发生一种叫做抗原转变的现象。这是一个更加戏剧性的转变
when a single cell hosts two separate and distinct strains of influenza and during the reproduction process, recombines those two parental strains into a new hybrid virus, a virus for which no one is prepared, no one has immunity. So of course because the virus sort of strikes with some regularity every year, people have developed some immunity, your point is that when the virus mutates in this fashion, it essentially is striking a naive population. Exactly. So many people believe the 1918 outbreak in the United States
当单个宿主细胞承载两个独立的、不同的流感病毒株，并且在繁殖过程中，将这两个亲本病毒株重新组合成一个新的混合病毒，一种没有人准备好、没有人具有免疫力的病毒。所以当然，由于病毒每年都会以某种规律定期袭击，人们已经产生了一些免疫力，你的观点是，当病毒以这种方式发生变异时，它本质上是在袭击一个从未接触过该病毒的人群。完全正确。所以很多人认为美国1918年的疫情
first began at an army camp in Kansas. Tell me about Camp Funston. Well Camp Funston was one of many places in the United States where American soldiers were training for the First World War and that spring they experienced a somewhat unusual example of influenza. And as it traveled through the Army camps, a few pathologists noticed that there was something unusual, the post-mortem exams of the victim showed a kind of soggy lung. But in general, most Americans didn't notice it.
最初始于堪萨斯州的一个陆军营地。跟我讲讲芬斯顿营地。好吧，芬斯顿营地是美国许多供美国士兵为第一次世界大战进行训练的地点之一，那年春天，他们经历了一个有些不同寻常的流感案例。当它在各个陆军营地传播时，一些病理学家注意到了一些不寻常之处，受害者尸检显示肺部有一种湿透的现象。但总体而言，大多数美国人并没有注意到这一点。
And this first wave with its origins in Kansas would pass the United States almost entirely unnoticed, except by a few military epidemiologists. And so once it strikes in Cam Funston, soldiers presumably are moving about the country, they're moving from Cam to Cam, what happens to the virus? Well the virus of course is continuing to do its work of infecting American soldiers and traveling with them. First all over the country and then of course, is continuing to do its work of infecting American soldiers and traveling with them. First, all over the country, and then, of course, it will become more noticeable because it will travel with those American troops over to the European battlefields.
而这场起源于堪萨斯的第一波疫情几乎在不知不觉中掠过美国，除了少数几位军事流行病学家。因此，一旦它袭击芬斯顿营地，士兵们大概就在全国各地四处移动，他们从一个营地移动到另一个营地，病毒会怎么样？好吧，病毒当然继续在感染美国士兵并随他们一起旅行。首先是在全国各地，然后当然，它继续在感染美国士兵并随他们一起旅行。首先是在全国各地，然后当然，它会变得更加引人注目，因为它将随着这些美军去往欧洲战场。
By April, it's spread to the British and German forces. By May, the French troops are infected. And then, of course, by that summer, Italy and Spain will also be infected. By June it would infect Britain and in July citizens all over the continent of Europe would be infected with this first wave. So you mentioned a second ago of, that this pandemic is unfolding at a time when the world is engulfed in war. And the virus travels from the United States to Europe, to the countries of Europe, but it's also traveling to the theaters of war in Europe.
到4月份，它已经蔓延到英国和德国军队。到5月份，法军也被感染了。然后当然，到了那个夏天，意大利和西班牙也将被感染。到6月，它将感染英国，到了7月，欧洲大陆各地的公民都将被这第一波疫情感染。所以你刚才提到，这场大流行发生在一个世界陷入战争的时期。病毒从美国传播到欧洲，传播到欧洲国家，但它也传播到了欧洲的战争剧院。
Tell me what was happening on the Western Front Nancy. Well, of course, the Western Front is deep in the throes of this war. American troops are just beginning to arrive in large numbers in the spring of 1918, the nation had joined the war in April of 1917. So the war is ongoing. It is deep. Millions of people have already died in trench warfare. And by the spring of 1918, the United States has entered and we're
南希，告诉我西线当时发生了什么。好吧，当然，西线正深陷这场战争的水深火热之中。大批美军在1918年春季开始抵达，美国是在1917年4月加入战争的。所以战争仍在继续。它是深远的。数百万人已经在堑壕战中丧生。到了1918年春季，美国已经加入，我们正
beginning to see a new round of assaults and new round of battles and so the opportunity for the virus in a sense is unlimited. You have a virus ready to attack the very people who are in those trenches, the target audience for the virus, young people. So across the Western Front, which is essentially the dividing line between the German forces and the Allied forces, you have these trenches and you have this very lengthy period of trench warfare unfolding in World War I, conditions are pretty dismal. Health conditions, of course, are terrible. From the virus's perspective, of course, this is actually ideal conditions to spread and
开始看到新一轮的进攻和新一轮的战斗，因此对病毒来说，机会在某种程度上是无限的。你拥有一个随时准备攻击那些身处战壕中的人们的病毒，即病毒的目标受众——年轻人。因此，在本质上是德军和盟军之间分界线的西线上，你有这些战壕，并且在第一次世界大战中展开了这段非常漫长的堑壕战时期，那里的条件相当凄惨。当然，卫生条件糟糕透顶。从病毒的角度来看，当然，这实际上是传播的理想条件，并且
grow and mutate. Exactly. Not only do you have a number of people far too many close together, we know now that social distancing is the best thing we can do to prevent the virus's spread, but in 1918 you have large numbers of people both in training camps and then on the battlefields themselves, and these are often people with compromised health already. They're living in horrible conditions. They may be undernourished. They're certainly not sleeping well.
生长和变异。完全正确。你不仅拥有大量靠得太近的人，我们现在知道保持社交距离是防止病毒传播最好的方法，但在1918年，无论是在训练营还是在战场上，都有大量的人，而且这些人通常原本健康状况就已受损。他们生活在可怕的条件中。他们可能营养不良。他们肯定睡眠不足。
And so you have a large population that is simply an easy field in a sense for this virus. So the chronology here is that early in 1918, perhaps with the epicenter at Camp Funston, the virus starts to spread in the United States, primarily following the paths of soldiers. It goes to Europe. It mutates. It changes.
因此，你拥有一个庞大的人群，对这种病毒来说，在某种程度上这简直是一片易于收割的田野。所以这里的历史时间线是，在1918年初，可能以芬斯顿营地为中心，病毒开始在美国传播，主要沿着士兵的足迹。它去了欧洲。它变异了。它改变了。
It becomes more deadly. And then something really dramatic happens that August and in the fall of 1918. What happens, Nancy? Well, it's really an explosive moment. The virus emerges in this new form on three continents, almost simultaneously in Free Town, Sierra Leone, in Breast, France, and in Boston here in the United States, where it arrives on August 27th. And then over the course of just two months
它变得更加致命。然后在1918年8月和秋天，发生了一件非常戏剧性的事情。南希，发生了什么？嗯，这确实是一个爆发性的时刻。病毒以这种新形式在三大洲几乎同时出现：塞拉利昂的弗里敦、法国的布雷斯特，以及美国本土的波士顿，它于8月27日抵达那里。然后在短短两个月的时间里
by the end of October, the entire United States will be a washing disease from Buffalo to Birmingham, from Pittsburgh to Portland. No one will be able to hide from this illness. And the same thing is happening worldwide. And of course, the picture you've painted is that the virus having mutated and become in some ways more deadly in Europe when it returns to the United States, presumably it's much more dangerous now. That's exactly right. At this point it is both very, very contagious and also deadly. Probably about 28% of Americans will be sickened by the virus, and in the end, as I mentioned,
到10月底，整个美国都将被疾病淹没，从布法罗到伯明翰，从匹兹堡到波特兰。没有人能够躲过这场疾病。世界各地也在发生同样的事情。当然，你所描绘的画面是，病毒在欧洲发生变异并在某些方面变得更加致命之后，当它返回美国时，现在它大概危险得多了。完全正确。在这一点上，它既极具传染性，又具致命性。大约28%的美国人可能会被这种病毒感染，最终，正如我所提到的，
675,000 people in the United States will die. The morbidity rates in the United States will range in different communities, sometimes as high as 40%. The mortality rate is also very high, somewhere between 2 and 2.5%. To put that in perspective, seasonal influenza is at 0.1%. So this is something like 25 times as lethal as regular seasonal influenza. So, the second wave of the influenza epidemic runs through the fall of 1918, and as you've described, it's truly devastating. And then, almost incredibly, there is a third wave of the epidemic that strikes early in 1919.
美国有67.5万人将死亡。美国的发病率在不同社区中会有所不同，有时甚至高达40%。死亡率也非常高，大约在2%到2.5%之间。为了做个对比，季节性流感的死亡率是0.1%。所以这大约是普通季节性流感的25倍致命。因此，流感大流行的第二波贯穿了1918年秋季，正如你所描述的，它确实是毁灭性的。然后，几乎令人难以置信的是，1919年初爆发了第三波疫情。
What happens here in Nancy? It's horrific for communities, in many cases cases that are just coming off the second wave. Perhaps they've just reopened their schools. Stores are open again, perhaps movie theaters and saloons are up and running once again. And then people begin to sicken all over again. And they suffer through a third wave. Again, this time quite noticeable because Americans are on high alert, having just recovered from or in some cases still in the throes of the second wave. So again, people are
南希，这里发生了什么？对社区来说，这太可怕了，在许多情况下，这些社区刚刚摆脱第二波疫情。也许他们刚刚重新开学。商店重新开业，也许电影院和酒吧再次开门营业。然后人们开始再次生病。他们经受了第三波疫情的折磨。这一次同样非常引人注目，因为美国人正处于高度戒备状态，刚刚从第二波疫情中恢复过来，或者在某些情况下仍然深陷其中。所以人们又
just beginning to breathe again, just beginning to relax, and suddenly the disease is back. That's from influenza outbreaks tend to have what you call a U-shaped curve when it comes to the age of its victims. Most victims are very young children, very old people. Was that the case with the 1918-1919 epidemic? This was something else that made this particularly horrific. In 1918, the mortality chart had a W shape. In other words, those between the ages of 20 and 40 were particularly susceptible. And so in fact, almost 50% of the epidemic deaths in the United States were 20 to 40-year-olds. The very people who are the mothers and fathers of young children,
刚刚开始呼吸，刚刚开始放松，疾病突然又回来了。这就是为什么流感爆发在受害者年龄方面往往呈现所谓的U型曲线。大多数受害者是极年幼的儿童和极年老的老人。1918-1919年的大流行也是这种情况吗？这是使这次疫情特别恐怖的另一个原因。1918年，死亡率图表呈W形。换句话说，20至40岁之间的人群特别容易受到感染。因此，事实上，美国近50%的大流行死亡病例是20至40岁的人。正是那些作为幼童母亲和父亲的人，
they may be the teachers in schools, they're the firefighters and the police officers, they're the people who are in a sense, the guts of a society, the people who are keeping a place up and running, and that population was struck desperately by this particular virus. I'm wondering if this might be partly connected to the chronology that you unfolded a few moments ago. When the virus essentially traveled from the United States to Europe and spread in the theater of World War I, its primary victims wore people again
他们可能是学校的老师，是消防员和警察，在某种意义上，他们是社会的骨干，是维持一个地方正常运转的人，而这个群体遭到了这种特定病毒的致命打击。我想知道这是否可能与你刚才展开的时间线有部分联系。当病毒基本上从美国传播到欧洲并在第一次世界大战战场上蔓延时，它的主要受害者再次是那些人
in the prime of their lives, young men in their 20s and 30s, and obviously for the virus to essentially acquire a foothold in the trenches required the virus to mutate so that it would be effective among people in their 20s and 30s, which might explain why when it returned to the United States, the victims were not just the very young and the very old, but people in working-age people, often in the prime of their lives.
正值生命黄金期的20多岁和30多岁的年轻男子，显然，病毒要在战壕中基本上站稳脚跟，需要发生变异，以便在20多岁和30多岁的人群中发挥作用，这或许可以解释为什么当它返回美国时，受害者不仅是极年幼和极年老的人，还有处于工作年龄的人，他们通常正值生命中最黄金的时期。
That's a really interesting theory. Not being an epidemiologist, I won't go too far on this, but certainly the war played a fundamental role in furthering the virus, in facilitating its mutation, and the opportunity provided by all of those soldiers. Again, really was the groundwork laid out there for the virus. So some of the best accounts of the outbreak come to us, not from doctors and scientists, but from writers. Tell me the story of Catherine Porter and the novella she wrote about the 1918 Influenza epidemic. This is really a remarkable novel, one of the best sources we have on
这是一个非常有趣的理论。由于我不是流行病学家，我不会对此做过多的推测，但战争肯定在推动病毒传播、促成其变异以及所有那些士兵所提供的机会方面发挥了根本性的作用。再次强调，这确实为病毒奠定了基础。因此，关于这次疫情的一些最好的记录不是来自医生和科学家，而是来自作家。跟我讲讲凯瑟琳·波特的故事，以及她撰写的关于1918年流感大流行的中篇小说。这确实是一部非凡的小说，是我们拥有的关于
the influenza pandemic because it's told from the perspective of a patient rather than the perspective of a physician. Catherine Am Porter was a journalist living in Denver at the time and she wrote a novella later, years later in the 1930s, recounting her own experience with the influenza pandemic. She had sickened, and while she was sick, her dearly beloved young soldier named Adam also sickened, and he died. And when she woke up, she came back to a world that was not the one she had left. And she was was really quite tortured in a sense by the loss that she suffered and she was was really quite tortured in a sense by the loss that she suffered during the pandemic.
流感大流行的最佳资料之一，因为它是从患者的角度而不是从内科医生的角度讲述的。凯瑟琳·安·波特当时是一名住在丹佛的记者，她在多年后的20世纪30年代写了一部中篇小说，回忆了她自己经历流感大流行的遭遇。她生病了，在她生病期间，她深爱着的一个名叫亚当的年轻士兵也生病了，他死了。当她醒来时，她回到了一个不再是她离开时的世界。对于她在这次大流行中遭受的损失，她在某种程度上确实感到非常痛苦，并且对于她在这次大流行中遭受的损失，她在某种程度上确实感到非常痛苦。
And she gives us a full account, almost a blow by blow of what it was like to go through this illness. At the very beginning, she's not quite clear on what's happening because again, the pandemic was new. And so she talks at first about not being able to smell or see or hear. She says, I must have a fearful cold. And then she begins to talk about something much more fearful, much more frightening.
她为我们提供了一份详尽的叙述，几乎是逐一记录了经历这场疾病的感受。在一开始，她对正在发生的事情并不是很清楚，因为大流行对她来说是全新的。因此，她一开始谈到无法闻到、看到或听到。她说：“我一定得了严重的感冒。”然后她开始谈论更可怕、更让人恐惧的事情。
This is the beginning of the end of something. Something terrible is going to happen to me. I shant me bread and butter where I'm going. I'll will it to chuck. He has a venerable father to buy hooch for. I hope they let him have it. Oh Adam, I hope I see you once more before I go under with whatever is the matter with me. And she can't control going in and out. She keeps wishing that she can come out of her dream so that she can talk to him. I have pains in my chest and my head and my heart and their real. I am in pain all over and you are in such danger as I can't bear to
这是某种事物的终结的开始。可怕的事情将要发生在我身上。我可负担不起我去那里的面包和黄油。我要把它留给查克。他有一个可敬的父亲可以用来买私酒。我希望他们让他买到。哦，亚当，我希望在我被任何疾病击倒之前再见你一面。她无法控制自己意识的清醒与迷糊。她一直希望自己能从梦中醒来，这样她就能和他说话。“我的胸部、头部和心脏都在痛，它们是真的。我浑身都在痛，你处在我想都不敢想的巨大危险中。”
think about. And why can we not save each other? And at this point she's not actually able to see Adam. He's been called back to camp. By the time he tries to return to her in the novella, they will not allow him to see her. And so they never see each other again. And she goes off then into the delirium that was common with those who suffered deeply from this pandemic. At one point beforehand, she talks about loving to be alive.
为什么我们不能拯救彼此？此时她实际上无法见到亚当。他被召回了军营。当中篇小说中他试图回到她身边时，他们不允许他见她。所以他们再也没有见过彼此。接着，她陷入了深度遭受这场大流行折磨的人们所共有的谵妄状态。在之前的某个时刻，她谈到热爱活着。
She says to Adam, don't you love weather and the colors at different times of the day? And all the sounds and noises like children screaming in the next lot, and automobile horns and little bands playing in the street, and the smell of food cooking. She seems to want to be alive, and then once she's really sick and goes into this very high fever and a delirium, a kind of dreamlike unconscious state.
她对亚当说：“难道你不喜欢天气和一天中不同时刻的色彩吗？以及所有的声音和噪音，比如隔壁批地里尖叫的儿童，汽车喇叭和小乐队在街上演奏的声音，以及食物烹饪的香味。”她似乎渴望活着，然后一旦她真的生病了，陷入这种极高的高烧和谵妄状态，一种类似梦境的无意识状态。
She doesn't so much give up as embrace what's coming, which for her appears to be the beauty of what comes after life, what death looks like to her when she is on the very cusp of it. So one reason that you've looked at novels and other cultural artifacts is that historians have noted that the great pandemic of 1918, even though it costs so many lives, it was sort of quickly forgotten after the fact. Talk to me about this idea that in many ways, even though the effects of the pandemic were really horrific, it faded from public view at least, relatively quickly. It did, and it's one of the things that I think historians have kind of puzzled over and even marveled about. Some people will simply dismiss
与其说是放弃，不如说是拥抱即将到来的一切，对她来说，这似乎是生命之后的美丽，当她处于生命的边缘时，死亡对她来说是什么样子的。因此，你研究小说和其他文化产物的其中一个原因在于，历史学家已经注意到，1918年的大流行尽管夺去了那么多人的生命，但在事后却很快被遗忘了。跟我聊聊这个观点：尽管大流行的影响确实非常可怕，但在很大程度上，它从公众视野中淡出得相对较快。确实如此，我认为这是让历史学家感到有些困惑甚至惊叹的事情之一。有些人会直接不予理睬
it and say, well, this is what people do, HL Mankin wrote, that the human mind always tries to expunge the intolerable from memory just as it tries to conceal it while current. In fact, it seems to have been subsumed very easily under the memory of the war. It did happen concurrently initially, and the war was a much better story for the American people at this time. To remember the flu would be to admit to the lack of control that people had had over their own health. It would be to admit that the United States was not necessarily all-powerful, but was like everywhere else in the world, subject as victims to something beyond their control.
当时，HL·门肯写道，人类的大脑总是试图从记忆中抹去那些无法忍受的事情，就像它在事情发生时试图掩盖它们一样。事实上，这似乎非常轻易地就被淹没在大战的记忆中。它最初确实是与战争同时发生的，对当时的美国人民来说，战争是一个好得多的故事。记住流感，就等于承认人们对自己的健康缺乏控制。这就等于承认美国并不一定是全能的，而是和世界上的其他地方一样，作为受害者，受制于他们无法控制的力量。
You describe songs that have been sung about the flu, especially in the tradition of the blues. Yes. One of the rare places that we do see the story of the flu told are in blues lyrics. And I think it's because this was actually a genre that had space in it for the kind of message that this was a horrific event through which people had suffered and which left in its aftermath, people lost, confused and very frightened. As he Jenkins had a remarkable song called the 1919 Influenza Blues. It was in 1919, 1919, Yes, me and women were dead.
你描述了一些关于流感的歌曲，特别是蓝调传统的歌曲。是的。我们看到流感故事被讲述的罕见地方之一就是蓝调歌词中。我认为这是因为这实际上是一种流派，它有空间容纳这样一种信息：这是一场可怕的事件，人们在其中遭受了苦难，并在余波中留下了迷茫、困惑和极度恐惧的人们。Ashe Jenkins有一首出色的歌曲，叫做《1919年流感蓝调》。那是1919年，1919年，是的，男女都死了。
When that's done, Where's the doctors? Call of flu. Yes, me and women were dead. When they stopped, where's the doctors? Call of food. And another good one is blind Willie Johnson's Jesus is coming soon. And a year of 1980, God sent a mighty Tarzis. It killed me there a thousand,
当这一切结束时，医生在哪里？流感爆发了。是的，男女都死了。当他们停下来时，医生在哪里？流感爆发了。另一个好例子是盲人威利·约翰逊的《耶稣很快就要降临》。在1918年，上帝派出了一个强大的泰尔西斯。它杀死了那里成千上万的人，
oh man and on a sea. And both of these tell the story of people suffering and dying and that this was really all part of God's plan, that this was God's way of speaking to the people about they're having drifted from their faith or having acted in some ways that were either shameful or simply incongruous with their Christianity. When we come back, what the 1918 influenza pandemic and the coronavirus pandemic of 2020 reveal about human nature. You're listening to Hidden Brain and I'm Shankar Vedanto. This is NPR. I didn't account too, but the captain said, I love the tin-o,
哦，天哪，在海上。所有这些都讲述了人们遭受痛苦和死亡的故事，这其实都是上帝计划的一部分，这是上帝向人们传达信息的方式，告诉他们已经背离了信仰，或者做出了一些可耻的、或者与他们的基督教信仰不相容的行为。当我们回来时，1918年流感大流行和2020年冠状病毒大流行揭示了关于人性的什么。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是NPR。我没有考虑到，但船长说，我爱这个小家伙，
I don't want to want to do but I died, I got done on the earth to see the fun. Historian Nancy Bristow says the ferocity and virulence of the 1918 influenza pandemic caught the world by surprise. But in many ways, it shouldn't have been a surprise.
我不想做什么，但我死了，我去地球上看热闹了。历史学家南希·布里斯托说，1918年流感大流行的凶猛和病毒性让世界措手不及。但在很多方面，这本不应该让人感到意外。
The pandemic hit a world engulfed in war. We've seen how the movement of soldiers were a powerful vector for the virus, but it went deeper than that. Nancy, how did the conflict between nations change how they responded, especially when it came to taking steps to limit the spread of the virus? did, especially when it came to taking steps to limit the spread of the virus. The war again really facilitated the virus's work. In the United States, for instance, President Woodrow Wilson would never, and I say never, speak publicly about the pandemic, even as more than half a million Americans are dying of influenza, the President of the United States refused to speak of the crisis that was underway precisely because he was worried about the war effort. He was so preoccupied with the prosecution of the war that he feared that people would lose sight of the most important business at hand, which was for the United States to win the war.
这场大流行席卷了一个陷入战争的世界。我们已经看到士兵的流动是如何成为病毒的强大载体的，但情况远不止于此。南希，国家之间的冲突如何改变了它们的应对方式，特别是在采取措施限制病毒传播方面？是的，特别是在采取措施限制病毒传播方面。战争再次极大地促进了病毒的传播。例如，在美国，总统伍德罗·威尔逊绝对——我说的是绝对——不会公开谈论这场大流行，尽管超过五十万美国人死于流感，但美国总统却拒绝谈论正在进行的危机，这正是因为他担心战争的影响。他全神贯注于战争的进行，他害怕人们会忽视手头最重要的事情，那就是美国赢得战争。
I understand that this was not limited to the United States. The same thing was happening in Germany where people didn't want to communicate the idea that the epidemic was basically going to harm Germany or undermine the war effort. That's exactly right. And of course, what we need most in the midst of a pandemic is good, sound, direct information from public health experts. And that's what many governments were fearing to share with their people. And in fact, that's how we end up with the misnomer Spanish influenza. Spain was not participating in the First World War, and so they were actually willing
我知道这不仅限于美国。德国也发生了同样的事情，人们不想传达这样一种观点，即流行病基本上会损害德国或破坏战争努力。完全正确。当然，在大流行期间，我们最需要的是来自公共卫生专家的良好、稳妥、直接的信息。而这正是许多政府不敢与人民分享的。事实上，这就是我们最终得到“西班牙流感”这个误称的原因。西班牙没有参加第一次世界大战，所以他们实际上愿意
to share the reality of what was going on in their country quite publicly. And so there was this assumption that Spain was sick when no one else was, and people came to call it the Spanish flu. Quite unfairly, in fact, it may well have been an American flu. So I want to better understand the connections between the epidemic and human behavior by zooming in on what happened in one place, Kansas City. You write that when the second wave of the epidemic hit in the fall of 1918, this was the deadliest wave. How did the leaders of Kansas City respond? In fact, Kansas City had a relatively common response. Public Health experts asked for
相当公开地分享他们国家正在发生的事情的现实。因此，人们产生了一种假设，即当没有其他人生病时，西班牙病了，人们开始称之为西班牙流感。这很不公平，事实上，这很可能是一场美国流感。因此，我想通过聚焦于堪萨斯城这个地方发生的事情，来更好地理解流行病与人类行为之间的联系。你写道，当1918年秋天第二波疫情袭来时，这是最致命的一波。堪萨斯城的领导人们是如何应对的？事实上，堪萨斯城的反应相对普遍。公共卫生专家要求
there to be social distancing measures, and the city followed through closing public amusements and prohibiting large public gatherings. Again, that social distancing that now is a term that's become so familiar to all of us. But as happened in many, many cities, as the numbers of people being infected would begin to slow a bit, people would relax. Eventually, they would overturn those requirements or those restrictions. But of course, there's another wave coming. And with the arrival of another wave,
采取社交距离措施，该市也付诸行动，关闭了公共娱乐场所并禁止了大型公共集会。再次强调，这就是现在对我们所有人来说都非常熟悉的“保持社交距离”这个词。但正如在许多许多城市发生的那样，随着感染人数开始略有下降，人们放松了警惕。最终，他们推翻了这些要求或限制。但是，当然，另一波疫情即将到来。随着另一波疫情的到来，
the government wants to put back in place these same kinds of public health restrictions and the people are much less compliant, much less interested in following the rules. They figure if it didn't stop it, when we tried it last time, why should we bother to try it again? So there's a kind of turning away
政府希望重新实施这些相同的公共卫生限制，而人们的配合度要低得多，对遵守规则的兴趣也小得多。他们认为，如果我们上次尝试时没能阻止它，为什么我们还要费心再试一次？因此，人们开始出现一种背离
from the public health expertise precisely because the virus came back. But again, that's what viruses do. It was no failure on the part of public health that the virus could return. But it's so understandable, isn't it, which is that you know, you're trying to follow the public health guidelines and then the virus comes back and you start to question how good are these guidelines. And then perhaps you follow some of the social distancing requirements that I put in place. And you do that for a couple of months and it's difficult because schools are closed and businesses are closed and everyone's itching to get back to normal. And then the third wave hits.
公共卫生专业知识的倾向，仅仅是因为病毒卷土重来。但话说回来，这就是病毒的运作方式。病毒的卷土重来并不是公共卫生部门的失职。但这太可以理解了，不是吗？也就是说，你知道，你试图遵循公共卫生指南，然后病毒卷土重来，你开始质疑这些指南有多好。然后也许你遵循了我制定的一些社交距离要求。你这样做了几个月，这很困难，因为学校关闭了，企业关闭了，每个人都渴望恢复正常。然后第三波疫情袭来。
And at this point, when people say let's go back to social distancing, it's not surprising that people would say absolutely not. it's not surprising that people would say, absolutely not. It's not surprising at all. And I think it's a really important idea to put out in our minds that even if we follow the social distancing practices, people will continue to sick and people will continue to die. That doesn't mean that it's not working because those figures are going to be substantially lower than if we move forward without social distancing. But people get frustrated. Again, partly because it's really
在这一点上，当人们说让我们回到社交距离时，人们说绝对不，这也就不足为奇了。人们说绝对不，这并不奇怪。这一点也不奇怪。我认为这是一个非常重要的观点，我们需要铭记在心：即使我们遵循社交距离的做法，人们仍将继续生病，人们仍将继续死亡。这并不意味着它没有起作用，因为这些数字将大大低于我们在不保持社交距离的情况下向前推进时的数字。但人们感到沮丧。再次强调，部分原因是它真的很
inconvenient. It is not that fun to be quarantined. It's not that fun to not be able to leave your homes. So people are anxious to get back to regular life. And there's this suspicion that somehow, well, none of this is really working because people are still getting sick and dying. And there's this suspicion that somehow, well, none of this is really working because people are still getting sick and dying. But that's not how we measure the success when there were in the midst of a deadly pandemic. So, it's a really tricky thing, isn't it? Because the counterfactual, which is the number of people who might have died otherwise, that's something that a model is telling you. You have to sort of, in some ways, trust the math over how you're feeling at that point.
不方便。被隔离并不是那么好玩。无法离开家也不是那么好玩。因此，人们渴望回到正常生活。人们有一种怀疑，认为不知何故，这一切其实都没有真正起作用，因为人们仍然在生病和死亡。人们有一种怀疑，认为不知何故，这一切其实都没有真正起作用，因为人们仍然在生病和死亡。但当身处致命大流行之中时，这并不是我们衡量成功与否的标准。所以，这是一件非常棘手的事情，不是吗？因为反事实，也就是原本可能死亡的人数，是某种模型告诉你。在某种程度上，你必须相信数学，而不是你当时的感受。
That's right. In 1918, they didn't have that mapping available to them. They couldn't look at models that would tell them how many would have died. In fact, our assumption that the social distancing worked is based on really careful research that has been done by epidemiologists and social historians who've looked at research that has been done by epidemiologists and social historians who've looked at what took place in different communities and have been able to realize that places like Milwaukee, Wisconsin, or St. Louis, Missouri that followed the rules and really maintained their restrictions for the longer period of time, just were more successful in keeping the death rates down. You talk about the distinction between the city of Philadelphia and you just mentioned Milwaukee. These cities had a very different response to the outbreak.
没错。在1918年，他们没有那种可用的测绘技术。他们无法查看能告诉他们会有多少人死亡的模型。事实上，我们认为社交距离起作用的假设是基于流行病学家和社会历史学家所做的非常仔细的研究，他们研究了流行病学家和社会历史学家所做的研究，他们观察了不同社区发生的事情，并能够意识到像威斯康星州密尔沃基市或密苏里州圣路易斯市这样遵守规则并在更长时间内真正维持限制的城市，在控制死亡率方面取得了更大的成功。你谈到了费城和密尔沃基这两个城市之间的区别。这两个城市对疫情的反应截然不同。
Tell me what happened in those cities and then what the outcome was in terms of mortality as a result of the epidemic. In Philadelphia, they have a somewhat corrupt political situation at the time. Philadelphia's health commissioner,mer Crousson decides that even though the disease was spreading that the war was important and he'd allow the fourth Liberty loan parade and event to take place on September 28th. At this point we're already a month into it's having arrived in the United States. Some 200,000 people showed up for that March and by the end of the flu season in fact some 12,000 residents in Philadelphia had died.
告诉我这些城市发生了什么，以及由于疫情导致的死亡率结果是什么。在费城，他们当时面临着某种腐败的政治局势。费城卫生专员梅尔·克劳森（Merle Crouse）决定，尽管疾病正在蔓延，但战争很重要，他将允许第四次自由公债游行活动于9月28日举行。此时距离疫情传入美国已经一个月了。大约20万人参加了那场游行，到流感季节结束时，事实上费城有大约12000名居民死亡。
Now, with some other cities, they moved much more quickly. They prohibited those parades, and they were, in fact, able to cut the death rate in some cases by half. Was it partly because the residents in places like Milwaukee were much more cooperative, much more likely to listen to public health officials? That's part of it. In Milwaukee, they have a very well-established health board and health commission. They're very familiar. This is a city that has, during the progressive year, really embraced the idea of
现在，对于其他一些城市，他们的行动要快得多。他们禁止了这些游行，事实上，在某些情况下，他们能够将死亡率降低一半。部分原因是否是因为密尔沃基等地的居民更加合作，更有可能听取公共卫生官员的意见？部分原因是这样的。在密尔沃基，他们有一个非常成熟的卫生委员会和卫生局。他们非常熟悉。这是一个在进步时代真正拥抱了
experts and the possibilities of reforming our communities and moving towards healthier, cleaner, safer lives by way of following sort of what science can teach us. And so Milwaukee had a very robust public health system. People were familiar with it. And in turn, because they had a good health board in place, they were able, I think, politically to do the work that needed to be done, to get those restrictions in place, to keep them in place for the longer period. And in fact, to do more things in Milwaukee, for instance, they use quarantining as well as closing spaces, prohibiting meetings and asking about the possibilities of public masking. They went all the way to enforcing quarantine as well. It really speaks to the importance of public institutions and the trust that people have in those institutions when catastrophes try, isn't it? Absolutely. And that's one of the things I
专家的理念以及通过遵循科学教给我们的东西来改造我们的社区并走向更健康、更清洁、更安全的生活的可能性的城市。因此，密尔沃基拥有一个非常健全的公共卫生系统。人们对此很熟悉。反过来，因为他们有一个良好的卫生委员会，我认为他们在政治上能够做需要做的工作，将这些限制措施落实到位，并在更长的时间内保持这些限制。事实上，在密尔沃基做了更多的事情，例如，他们不仅关闭空间、禁止集会并询问公众佩戴口罩的可能性，还使用了隔离措施。这确实说明了公共机构的重要性以及在灾难降临时人们对这些机构的信任，不是吗？绝对是的。这就是其中一件事我
worry about right now is the faith in government is a little bit shaker in 2020 and it's going to be very important as we go forward to listen carefully to those public health leaders in particular, the experts who really know what they're talking about. And in 1918, in those communities where people did that, it really did make a difference. You describe how in Roanoke, Virginia, people with mild cases of the flu or people who had had the flu and recovered, decided that quarantines really weren't for them anymore. And this is again totally understandable. People were starting to shave after a few days or a few weeks of enforced restrictions. And they said, all right, I've sort of come out the other side, I'm fine. I can go about my daily business, again, completely human, but potentially really dangerous. Very dangerous, not only for the individual who may have a relapse, may not in fact be
现在担心的是，2020年人们对政府的信任度有些动摇，随着我们向前迈进，仔细倾听那些公共卫生领导人，尤其是那些真正知道自己在说什么的专家的意见，将是非常重要的。在1918年，在那些人们这样做的社区里，它确实发挥了作用。你描述了在弗吉尼亚州罗阿诺克，轻度流感患者或已经感染流感并康复的人决定隔离对他们来说已经不再适用。这也是完全可以理解的。在经过几天或几周的强制限制后，人们开始刮胡子。他们说，好吧，我算是在另一边熬过来了，我很好。我可以继续我的日常生活，同样，这完全是人之常情，但可能非常危险。非常危险，不仅对可能复发、实际上可能还没有
fully healthy yet, but also for those around them. Their families would become ill or those who shops they went to, the people who might sit next to them in a movie theater, so extraordinarily dangerous to assume that one is healthy before one is verifiably over these illnesses, because you can continue to shed the virus even after you begin to feel healthy. I want to be cautious about one point. You know, when we hear about RONOQ or the difference between Philadelphia and Milwaukee, you know, we know the people in RONOQ are breaking quarantine, we're making a mistake.
完全恢复健康的个人来说如此，对他们周围的人也是如此。他们的家人会生病，或者他们光顾的商店的人，那些可能坐在他们电影院座位旁边的人，所以在经证实从这些疾病中恢复之前就假设自己是健康的，是极其危险的，因为即使在你开始感觉健康之后，你仍会继续排出病毒。我想对一点保持谨慎。你知道，当我们听到罗阿诺克或费城与密尔沃基之间的区别时，你知道，我们知道罗阿诺克的人在打破隔离，我们在犯错误。
We know that Milwaukee got it right and Philadelphia got it wrong. But in some ways Nancy, I'm wondering if we know this because we know now how the pandemic turned out. We have the advantage of hindsight. There have probably been dozens of other disease outbreaks where the Philadelphia response might have been just fine. What I'm trying to get at is that there are huge social and economic consequences from shutting down schools and businesses and those can harm people's lives too.
我们知道密尔沃基做对了，费城做错了。但在某些方面，南希，我想知道我们是否知道这一点，是因为我们现在知道了大流行的结局。我们有事后诸葛亮的优势。可能还有几十次其他疾病爆发，费城的反应可能完全没问题。我想表达的是，关闭学校和企业会产生巨大的社会和经济后果，这些也会危害人们的生活。
And I guess what I'm trying to say is that policymakers, when something is unfolding, when an epidemic is unfolding, it's really difficult to actually know exactly what the right thing is to do because they're potentially devastating consequences, regardless of which choice you pursue. That's so true. And it's one of the things I was worrying about on my way into work this very morning, as we're closing schools, those hundreds of thousands of children who rely on school breakfast lunch and in some cases even dinner. So policymakers in 1918 did not have the benefit of hindsight that we have as we look back at them. So you're
我想说的是，当事情正在展开时，当流行病正在展开时，决策者很难真正知道正确的事情是什么，因为无论你选择哪种选择，都可能产生毁灭性的后果。确实如此。这也是我今天早晨上班路上担心的事情之一，当我们关闭学校时，那成千上万依赖学校早餐、午餐甚至有时是晚餐的儿童。因此，1918年的决策者没有我们在回首他们时所拥有的事后诸葛亮的优势。所以你是
right that in some ways the critique of the policymakers really does have to be softened a bit. In many cases, they really were doing the best they could. Now in some cases, I think we have corrupt politicians in some communities that are really thinking more about their political futures than the health of their communities. In those cases, I think it is a little easier to point a finger. But again and again and again, we have to remember how difficult this is when you don't know where the pandemic is going. And that is something that I think I've never understood as well as I have in the last week.
对的，在某些方面，对决策者的批评确实必须有所缓和。在许多情况下，他们确实在尽最大努力。现在在某些情况下，我认为我们有一些社区的腐败政治家，他们更多地考虑自己的政治前途，而不是社区的健康。在这些情况下，我认为指责起来会容易一些。但一次又一次，我们必须记住，当你不知道大流行将走向何方时，这是多么困难。我认为这是我过去一周才真正深刻理解的事情。
I'm wondering if one of the deeper lessons here is not so much that some people were right and some people were wrong, but that, you know, as the catastrophe was unfolding, many people really didn't change their behavior. It's really difficult to get people to change their behavior for any length of time. That's right. And in 1918, we have to remember that the notion of germ theory had certainly caught on and was certainly fully embraced by the vast majority of health providers. But for the general public, there were still a lot
我想知道，这里更深层的教训与其说是某些人对了某些人错了，不如说是，当灾难展开时，许多人的行为确实没有改变。要让人们在任何一段时间内改变他们的行为都非常困难。没错。在1918年，我们必须记住，细菌学理论的概念肯定已经流行起来，并且肯定得到了绝大多数卫生提供者的充分接受。但对于广大公众来说，仍然有很多
of questions out there about how disease was transmitted. So the idea that washing your hands was important or that you wouldn't all drink out of the same drinking cup was relatively foreign for some people. In fact, it's during this pandemic that most American cities finally banned the common drinking cup at places where people would gather to get water. So again, it was hard for people because on the one hand it's inconvenient, and on the other, they were asking for new habits, things that they had always been allowed to do before, and suddenly you're not allowed, for instance, to spit on the street, or to share a drinking cup. That you had to cover your cough and sneeze in your elbow. These were new things people were being asked to do in 1918.
关于疾病是如何传播的疑问。因此，洗手很重要或者你们不会共用同一个饮水杯的想法对某些人来说相对陌生。事实上，正是在这次大流行期间，大多数美国城市最终禁止了人们聚集取水地方的公共饮水杯。所以再次强调，这对人们来说很难，因为一方面很不方便，另一方面，他们被要求养成新的习惯，做一些他们以前一直被允许做的事情，而突然之间你不被允许了，例如，在街上吐痰，或者共用一个饮水杯。你必须在咳嗽和打喷嚏时用手肘遮挡。这些是1918年人们被要求做的新事情。
One of the things I found really interesting is that you cite a number of letters in your book. These were letters written during the time of the 1918 pandemic. One of them was written by the Aviatrix, Amelia Earhart. Others were written by men. What did these letters say and what did they, what did they reveal? by man, what did these letters say and what did they, what did they reveal? It's very interesting the ways in which the reactions to the pandemic were actually somewhat gendered. We find that in the midst of this catastrophe, as people are wrestling with something so new to them, that there's a great deal of sort of looking for security in how things are commonly done, in grabbing hold of our traditional patterns and behaviors.
我发现非常有趣的一件事是，你在书中引用了许多信件。这些信件是1918年大流行期间写的。其中一封是女飞行员阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特写的。其他的是由男性写的。这些信件写了什么，它们揭示了什么？由男性写的，这些信件写了什么，它们揭示了什么？人们对大流行的反应实际上在某种程度上具有性别差异，这非常有趣。我们发现，在这个灾难中，当人们与对他们来说如此新奇的事情作斗争时，很大程度上是在如何按常理办事的习惯中寻找安全感，在抓住我们的传统模式和行为。
And so for women, it was much more common for them in their letters to talk about what they were seeing, how frightened they were, giving detailed outlines of who in the family or who in the friend groups were ill and what was going on, and really admitting up front how frightening it all was. And again, it feels so typical because you sort of see some of the same things happening today. I feel like you have people reacting in fairly predictable ways. Some people saying we really have to be anxious and other people saying that it's going to blow over in a couple of weeks. I think that's right. What's interesting is the ways in which in 1918 it is so profoundly about
所以对女性而言，在信件中谈论她们所见所感、她们有多害怕、详细描述家里或朋友圈里有谁生病以及发生了什么，并且在一开始就坦白这一切究竟有多可怕，这些要常见得多。再说，这感觉太典型了，因为你有点能看到今天也正在发生着一些类似的事情。我觉得你会发现人们的反应有着相当强的可预测性。有些人说我们真的必须感到焦虑，而另一些人则说这几周就会过去。我想是这样的。有趣的是，在1918年，这种性别特征是如何深刻地
being male and female so that someone as well known as Amelia Earhart as she will become known, right, as a great aviatrix, said of the flu, I hate and fear it, somehow more than a little. Having seen so much of it, I suppose, has prejudiced me with the very uncertainty of treatment adding to the prejudice. She was working in an Influenza Award, knew what it looked like, and was sharing this with one of her dear friends.
体现为男性和女性之分，以至于像后来成为大名鼎鼎的伟大女飞行员阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特这样知名的人，在谈到流感时曾说：“不知为何，我比想象中更讨厌并害怕它。我想，由于见识了太多这种病，加上治疗的不确定性，这种偏见已经在我的心中根深蒂固。”她当时在一个流感病房工作，深知这种病的恐怖，并与她的一位挚友分享了这些感受。
And meanwhile, men are worrying about not getting into the office and sending notes to one another, apologizing for missing another day of work in the midst of the war. You also note how gender in the form of social norms played a very powerful role. You interviewed a survivor of the 1918 epidemic when she was 85 years old. Can you tell me the story of Lillian Kanceyannich? I can.
与此同时，男人们则在担心无法去办公室，并互相发便条，在战争期间因为又错过了一天的工作而致歉。你还注意到，以社会规范形式存在的性别扮演了多么强有力的角色。你采访过一位1918年大流行的幸存者，当时她85岁。你能给我讲讲莉莲·坎西安尼奇的故事吗？可以的。
This is a lovely woman lived in Tacoma when I interviewed her several years ago, and she had lost her mother when she was only three months old. And in her community, it was felt that men shouldn't live alone with daughters, that they could not adequately raise children on their own. And so she and her sister were sent away, her sister to live some ways away with family.
这是一位非常可爱的女士，几年前我采访她时，她住在塔科马。她在仅仅三个月大时就失去了母亲。在她的社区里，人们认为男人不应该单独和女儿生活在一起，他们无法独自抚养好孩子。因此，她和她的姐姐被送走了，她的姐姐去了离家有些路程的亲戚那里生活。
And Lillian was actually traded between members of the family for a couple of years before she finally was able to move in to a permanent situation with relatives in the same town as her father. But she remembered for the rest of her life that this had cost her something. She didn't remember her mother, but she remembered that she was somehow different from others. She knew that she and her sister had lost valuable years together during their youth and she felt that her life had been changed. She said that it had changed my life completely. It had to.
而莉莲实际上在几年的时间里被家里的不同成员转手寄养，直到她最终能够搬去和她父亲在同一个小镇的亲戚家过上稳定的生活。但她在余生中都记得，这让她付出了代价。她不记得自己的母亲，但她记得自己不知何故与别人不同。她知道她和姐姐在年幼时失去了宝贵的一起生活的时光，她觉得她的人生已经被改变了。她说这完全改变了我的人生。它必然会如此。
At one level of virus is a biological organism. It's a creature of natural selection. It follows rules that have been studied for decades by epidemiologists. But at another level, a virus is a social organism. It detects fissures in societies and exposes fault lines between communities. That's when we come back. I'm Shankar Vedantum and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. Nancy Bristo is the author of American Pandemic, the Lost Worlds of the 1918 Influenza Epidemic.
从某种层面来看，病毒是一种生物有机体。它是自然选择的产物，遵循着被流行病学家研究了几十年的规律。但从另一个层面来看，病毒是一种社会有机体。它能探测到社会的裂痕，并暴露社区之间的断层线。我们稍后回来。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这是美国国家公共广播电台。南茜·布里斯托是《美国大流行：1918年流感大流行的失落世界》一书的作者。
She has studied the lessons of the deadly outbreak a century ago, and she sees historical parallels with our own battle against the coronavirus. Nancy, you describe how the Red Cross once went into a rural and disadvantaged part of Kentucky to help residents affected by the 1918 epidemic. How did volunteers relate to the patients? Well, in the case of Kentucky, not very well, as was common often with visiting nurses as they would enter homes or communities that were not like their own middle class upbringing, they would look down their noses somewhat disparagingly at the conditions that they found. And in
她研究了一个世纪前那场致命疫情的教训，并看到了它与我们自身抗击冠状病毒之战的历史相似之处。南茜，你描述了红十字会曾如何进入肯塔基州一个偏远且处于劣势的地区，去帮助受1918年大流行影响的居民。志愿者们是如何与患者相处的？嗯，就肯塔基州的情况而言，并不是很好。正如通常访问护士的情况一样，当她们进入那些与她们的中产阶级成长环境不同的家庭或社区时，她们会有所俯视，带着些许贬低的情绪看待她们所发现的状况。而且在
the case of Kentucky would say terrible things, in fact, they talked about them being desperately poor, but they would also go on to say things like they were ignorant of the simplest principles of sanitation and hygiene, that they were living in crowded quarters, and they would almost make it seem as if the poor were responsible, in fact, for their own situation, and that they were, in fact for their own situation and that they were in fact causing the very epidemic conditions from which they were reeling. You would imagine it would be difficult for the volunteers to truly play a helping role when they had such attitudes about the people they were trying to help.
肯塔基州的情况下，她们会说一些可怕的话。事实上，她们谈到当地人极度贫困，但她们接着还会说诸如他们对最简单的环境卫生和个人卫生原则一无所知、他们居住在拥挤的环境中之类的话，她们甚至几乎让人们觉得，穷人其实要为他们自己的处境负责，事实上，他们正是自己正在饱受其苦的流行病环境的始作俑者。你可以想象，当志愿者对他们试图帮助的人抱有这种态度时，他们很难真正发挥帮助者的作用。
I think that's right. In some cases, they could be useful and it was usually I think especially those who had a much more compassionate and empathetic approach to those who were not just like them, who could enter a home and recognize that the reason it was dirty was because both parents were working. The reason that there wasn't as much clothing or as clean of clothing was because the family was strapped. The reason it was cold was because perhaps they couldn't afford to buy coal. And so again, those who could recognize difference as coming not from innate human lacking, but rather from circumstance,
我想是的。在某些情况下，他们可能会发挥作用，而且通常我认为，特别是那些对与自己不同的人抱有更多同情心和同理心的人，他们能够走进一个家里，并认识到房子脏是因为父母双方都在工作；衣服少或不够干净是因为家庭经济窘迫；家里冷是因为他们可能买不起煤。因此，同样地，那些能够认识到这种差异并非源于天生的人性缺陷，而是源于环境、
from actual social conditions, those were the people I think who had the most opportunity to facilitate good health and to actually help people move forward out of this pandemic towards health. How did these class divisions and class attitudes shape the way people reached out to others in terms of charitable donations, in terms of being willing to extend a helping hand? Did people in general and the public see the poor as essentially being somehow responsible for their illnesses? At this time, there really was a lot of distinguishing by those in the middle and upper classes that among the poor, there were those who were worthy
源于实际社会条件的人，我认为他们才是最有机会促进健康、真正帮助人们走出这场大流行迈向健康的人。这些阶级划分和阶级态度是如何塑造人们向他人伸出援手的方式的？无论是在慈善捐赠方面，还是在愿意提供援助之手方面？公众和普通大众是否认为穷人本质上要对他们生病负某种责任？在当时，中产阶级和上层阶级确实对穷人进行了很多区分，认为穷人中有值得帮助的
and those who were not. And to be worthy meant a few very particular things, one, it meant that everyone in the household was working. In other words, if you're going to pull yourself up by your bootstraps, everybody better be helping with the poll. In other cases, if families didn't adhere to certain American traditions, they might have a different spiritual system. They may have come from a different part
和不值得帮助的。而所谓“值得帮助”意味着几个非常特定的条件：第一，这意味着家里每个人都在工作。换句话说，如果你想靠自己的力量摆脱困境，最好每个人都在出力。在其他情况下，如果家庭不遵守某些美国传统，他们可能会有不同的精神信仰。他们可能来自世界的
of the world and not speak English yet. Anything that made them seem somehow different would also sometimes categorize people as the other, in a sense, and make them somehow more suspicious, not quite as, quote, worthy of the kind of care that charitable organizations were happy to give to some people. I'm thinking of some of the fissures that are already emerging in the present day in the United States and the context of the coronavirus. You know, if you're a white collar worker who can work from home on your computer, it's an inconvenience to stay home, but it's not really devastating to you.
不同地方，还不会说英语。任何让他们显得有些不同的事物，有时也会在某种意义上将人们归类为“异类”，让他们变得更加可疑，不那么“配得上”慈善机构乐于提供给某些人的那种关怀。我想到了美国当前已经开始出现的一些裂痕，以及冠状病毒的背景。你知道，如果你是一名可以在家里的电脑上工作的白领，待在家里只是一种不便，但对你来说并不是毁灭性的。
You're still getting paid, you still have your health benefits, but if you're an hourly worker, a gig economy worker, a contractor without health insurance, this can actually be a disaster. That's exactly right. And it was true in 1918 as well. The associate charities of Minneapolis worked with a family listed only as the, quote, D family, but they tell this story of a man who had done everything right, had been working hard, and then
你仍然在拿薪水，你仍然拥有健康福利，但如果你是一名按小时计工的工人、零工经济从业者、没有医疗保险的承包商，这实际上可能是一场灾难。完全正确。1918年也是如此。明尼阿波利斯的联合慈善会曾帮助过一个只被列为“D”姓的家庭，他们讲述了这样一个故事：一个男人做对了所有事情，一直在努力工作，然后
was stricken by the pandemic. By the time they reported in for charitable aid, they already needed groceries. They'd used all of the money that they had saved. He was trying to return, but was too sick. His children were getting ill. And by the time they visited his home, they were absolutely without coal. He borrowed a pale fold from a woman down stairs from his apartment.
被这场大流行击倒了。当他们去申请慈善援助时，他们已经需要食品杂货了。他们用光了所有的积蓄。他试图回去工作，但病情太重了。他的孩子们也开始生病。当他们去探访他的家时，家里绝对是一点煤都没有了。他从公寓楼下一位女性那里借了一个小桶。
The groceries were completely gone, and he could not get any credit at the grocery store. At this point, Mr. D, as they referred to him, simply broke down and cried, saying, everything was against him. It wasn't his fault, his problems didn't originate in fact with the epidemic, but in his insecure situation, which was then made much worse by the bout with influenza. And I fear we're going to be seeing the exact same thing right now. I'm wondering, you know, when I'm thinking about the present moment, how this might play out here, where people, you know, you talk about sort of the mortality rate of the coronavirus, but that mortality rate is likely to be very different in different places, is it not? I mean, if
杂货已经全没了，他在杂货店也赊不到任何东西。此时，他们口中的D先生彻底崩溃并哭了起来，说所有事情都在与他作对。这不是他的错，他的问题实际上并不是源于这场大流行，而是源于他那缺乏保障的境遇，而这境遇随后因那场流感而变得更加糟糕。我担心我们现在就会看到完全相同的情况。我在想，你知道的，当我思考当下时，这种情况可能会在这里如何演变？人们，你知道的，你谈到了冠状病毒的死亡率，但这种死亡率在不同的地方可能会有很大不同，不是吗？我的意思是，如果你
you're wealthy, if you're living in a part of the country that has excellent medical care, if you have access to health insurance, your mortality rate is likely to look very different than somebody who's poor or living in a rural part of the country or living in a part of the country where they don't have access to healthcare. I think that's right. And again, I'm not an epidemiologist nor my physician, but it seems that this particular crisis with COVID-19 is going to matter who has access to healthcare. For instance, the availability of a ventilator is going to be really crucial for those in really critical condition so that there's going to be really crucial for those in really critical condition.
很富有，如果你住在医疗条件极佳的国家地区，如果你能获得医疗保险，你的死亡率看起来可能会与那些贫穷、住在偏远地区或无法获得医疗保健的人非常不同。我想是的。再说一次，我既不是流行病学家也不是医生，但这场针对COVID-19的特定危机似乎确实取决于谁能获得医疗保健。例如，呼吸机的可用性对于那些处于危重状态的人来说至关重要，因此这对于那些处于危重状态的人将至关重要。
So that there's going to be a really inequitable landing of this virus and of this illness, depending on one's social position, one's economic position, one's place in the racial hierarchy of the country. All of these things will be playing out, I fear, as people have inequitable access to health care. You mentioned the racial hierarchy a second ago. And of course, this was true in 1918 as well. You tell the story of how enrichment African Americans were allowed access to a hospital where whites were being treated, but there was a catch.
因此，这种病毒和疾病的降临将是非常不公平的，这取决于一个人的社会地位、经济地位以及在国家种族等级制度中的地位。我担心，随着人们无法平等地获得医疗保健，所有这些事情都将上演。你刚才提到了种族等级制度。当然，1918年也是如此。你讲了一个故事：在里士满，非裔美国人被允许进入一家为白人治疗的医院，但有一个附加条件。
Yes, they could certainly visit this new emergency hospital at John Marshall High School. The problem is that they were only allowed to be treated in the basement, where a separate space had been opened up. And was the treatment quality different in the basement than it was in the main hospital? One has only to imagine. I have no way of knowing for certain, but again, we know that segregation had made two very distinct health systems in African African Americans were routinely under-treated. In 1915, the life expectancy for white Americans was 55.1.
是的，他们当然可以参观约翰·马歇尔高中这所新的应急医院。问题在于，他们只被允许在地下室接受治疗，那里开辟了一个单独的区域。地下室的治疗质量与主医院有区别吗？人们只能想象。我无法确切知道，但同样地，我们知道种族隔离造成了两个截然不同的医疗系统，非裔美国人经常得不到充足的治疗。1915年，美国白人的预期寿命是55.1岁。
While for African Americans, it was only 38.9 years. So a huge differential in life expectancy prior to the pandemic. So we certainly have to assume that in the midst of the pandemic, the kind of care that was creating that differential was also happening. What's odd in 1918 is that there's no evidence necessarily that access to healthcare changed the death rate particularly. It's certainly changed how comfortable people were, however. I understand that some black pastors offered sermons that used the 1918 outbreak as a way to argue for social justice and social change.
而对于非裔美国人来说，只有38.9岁。因此，在大流行之前，预期寿命存在巨大的差异。所以我们当然必须假设，在大流行期间，造成这种差异的医疗护理方式也同样存在。1918年奇怪的是，没有证据表明获得医疗保健必然改变了死亡率。不过，它当然改变了人们的舒适程度。我听说一些黑人牧师发表了布道，将1918年的疫情作为争取社会正义和变革的论据。
That's right. There were those who resisted this clinging to the status quo who saw in the epidemic actually an opportunity to shake up the hierarchies, to call out that which was unjust. My favorite example of this was the Reverend Francis Grimke. He was an important advocate for African-American rights and worked at the 15th Street Presbyterian Church in Washington, D.C. his church. And he really believed that God was trying to awaken Americans to the sacrilege of the caste system.
是的。有些人拒绝抱残守缺，他们实际上将大流行视为打破等级制度、大声疾呼不公正现象的契机。我最喜欢的例子是弗朗西斯·格林姆基牧师。他是争取非裔美国人权益的重要倡导者，曾在华盛顿特区的第十五街长老会教堂工作，也就是他的教堂。他坚信上帝正试图唤醒美国人，让他们认识到种姓制度的亵渎。
He said, what oughted to mean to us, this pandemic? Every part of the land has felt its deadly touch north-south, east and west, in the army, in the Navy, among civilians, among all classes and conditions, rich in poor, high and low, white and black. And he concluded, God has been trying, in a very pronounceedly conspicuously and vigorous way, to beat a little sense into the white man's head,
他说：“这场大流行对我们意味着什么？土地的每个角落都感受到了它致命的触角：北方、南方、东方、西方；在军队里，在海军里，在平民中，在所有阶层和境况中——富裕与贫穷，高贵与卑微，白人与黑人。”他总结道：“上帝一直试图以一种非常明显、显眼且有力的方式，把一点常识打进白人的脑袋里，
has been trying to show him the folly of the empty conceit of his vanted race superiority by dealing with him just as he dealt with the people of darker hue. He was convinced that the epidemic scourge was actually God's work, and he was trying in a sense, as he said it, to teach the white man the quote folly of his stupid color prejudice." End quote. One of the things that strikes me as you're describing these various responses is how little people actually changed from what they believed or thought before the outbreak began. And what I mean by that is, if you're a black pastor and you're advocating against white supremacy, the outbreak becomes a mechanism for you to argue against white supremacy, the outbreak becomes a mechanism for you
一直试图通过像对待皮肤较黑的人那样对待白人，来让他明白其吹嘘的种族优越感的空洞自负是何等愚蠢。”他确信这场流行病灾难实际上是上帝的作为，从某种意义上说，正如他所说，他正试图教导白人所谓“其愚蠢的肤色偏见的愚蠢之处”。正如他所说。在听你描述这些不同的反应时，让我感到震惊的一件事是，人们对疫情爆发前自己所信仰或思考的事物，其实并没有做出多少改变。我的意思是，如果你是一个黑人牧师，并且在主张反对白人至上主义，那么疫情就成了你反对白人至上主义的工具，疫情就成了你
to argue against white supremacy. If you're a fairly high up in the class hierarchy and you look down on poor people, the outbreak becomes a vehicle for you to express your class prejudice. If you're interested in prosecuting a war, then the virus becomes a way for you to say, you know, fighting the virus is a way for you to say, you know, fighting the virus
反对白人至上主义的工具。如果你在阶级等级中处于相当高的位置并且看不起穷人，那么疫情就成了你表达阶级偏见的载体。如果你有兴趣进行一场战争，那么病毒就成了你的一种方式，让你说，你知道的，抗击病毒是一种方式，让你说，你知道的，抗击病毒
is a way to win the war. And I'm seeing actually some curious parallels with the present moment as well, which is as soon as the coronavirus outbreak began, you saw people from different parts of the political spectrum, different interest groups, all sort of essentially using the outbreak to basically say, look, the point of view that I had before this actually happened, all this does is confirm everything that I believe to be true. I'm afraid that's what I'm seeing as well, whether it's the xenophobia that we saw expressed against people who appeared to be aversion to scent or this willingness to say that actually we
是赢得战争的一种方式。事实上，我也看到了与当下的一些奇妙相似之处，那就是冠状病毒疫情爆发后不久，你就会看到来自政治光谱不同部分、不同利益集团的人们，基本上都在利用疫情来说：“看，这实际上证实了我在这件事发生之前就持有的观点，这一切所做的只是证实了我一直以来认为真实的一切。”恐怕这也是我所看到的，无论是我们对那些表现得好像对某种气味有厌恶感的人所表现出的仇外心理，还是这种愿意声称实际上我们
have everything in hand because our government knows what it's doing, these kinds of tendencies to simply rely on what we already believe is not actually going to help us effectively manage what is not just a national crisis, but an international crisis. For Americans, many of whom I fear think of us as somehow exceptional. This is a moment to step away from that kind of belief and to recognize ourselves as citizens in fact of a world that is wrestling with this pandemic. And my hope is that maybe this time around we can be a bit more sensitive, a bit more culturally aware, and perhaps embrace that sort of world citizenship, because that's
一切尽在掌握因为我们的政府知道自己在做什么的倾向，这种仅仅依靠我们已经相信的事物的倾向，实际上并不能帮助我们有效地管理这场不仅是国家危机、而且是国际危机的事件。对于许多我担心认为我们具有某种特殊性的美国人来说，这是一个摆脱这种信念、认识到我们实际上是这个正在与这场大流行病搏斗的世界中的公民的时刻。我的希望是，也许这一次我们可以更加敏感一些，具备更多的文化意识，也许能够拥抱那种世界公民意识，因为那是
the route, I think, to handling this scourge in the most effective way. You're speaking to me from the campus of your university, which is in Tacoma, Washington, and as we record this interview, the state of Washington has been especially hard hit by the coronavirus outbreak. What have you seen yourself these last few days, Nancy, and what parallels are you seeing with the 1918 outbreak? Well, as you mentioned a little bit ago, one thing we've seen right away is the differential and who's able to stay home, who can do this remote work, and who is being forced to
我认为以最有效的方式应对这场灾难的途径。你现在是从位于华盛顿州塔科马的你的大学校园里跟我说话的，在我们录制这次采访时，华盛顿州受冠状病毒疫情的打击尤其严重。南茜，这几天你亲眼看到了什么？你看到了哪些与1918年疫情相似的地方？嗯，正如你刚才稍微提到的那样，我们立刻看到的一件事是关于谁能待在家、谁能进行远程办公、以及谁被迫
continue to go to their job. So at my university, of course, faculty were encouraged to teach remotely. We will be encouraging our young people to stay home after spring break for an undetermined length of time. So those of us with privilege have been able to do social distancing somewhat easily and I will continue to be paid and they will continue to learn. At the very same moment as I arrived on campus this morning, of course, custodial staff are here. Those who work in our lunch room are here. So those who are working blue-collar jobs, let's say, have less opportunity to practice
继续去上班的差异。所以在我的大学里，教职员工当然被鼓励进行远程教学。我们也将鼓励我们的年轻人春假后在家待上一段时间，时间长短未定。因此，我们这些享有特权的人能够相对轻松地保持社交距离，我将继续拿到薪水，他们也将继续学习。与此同时，就在今天早上我到达校园时，我们的后勤人员当然都在这里。在我们的餐厅工作的人都在这里。因此，那些从事蓝领工作的人，比方说，他们实践
social distancing because they may be required by their employers to go to work. Or alternatively, many workers are going to be simply forced not to go to work, in which case the Uber driver and the waiter are going to be losing the money on which they rely day by day by day. So those of us with salaries, those of us who can work remotely, we're going to be much safer in a sense, and we're also going to continue to make a living. While those who are in more precarious financial contacts and situations will be, in fact, facing the greatest danger,
社交距离的机会较少，因为他们的雇主可能要求他们去上班。或者换句话说，许多工人将被迫不去上班，在这种情况下，优步司机和侍者将失去他们日复一日赖以生存的收入。因此，我们这些有薪水的人，我们这些可以远程工作的人，在某种意义上会安全得多，而且我们还将继续谋生。而那些处于更不稳定财务状况和境地的人，实际上将面临最大的危险，
more exposure to the virus or alternatively, not exposure, but simply the loss of their living. Nancy Pristow is a historian at the University of Puget Sound. She's the author of American Pandemic, the Lost Worlds of the 1918 Influenza Epidemic. Nancy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been an honor and a pleasure. Thank you so much. This week's show was produced by Raina Cohen. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Paath Shah, Laura Quarelle, Thomas Liu and Lushik Waba. Special thanks to Eileish O'Neil for production support, James Willets for Engineering Health, and to catch
面临更多的病毒暴露，或者换句话说，不是暴露于病毒，而是单纯失去生计。南茜·普里斯托是普吉特海湾大学的历史学家。她是《美国大流行：1918年流感大流行的失落世界》一书的作者。南茜，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。这真的是我的荣幸和快乐。非常感谢。本周的节目由蕾娜·科恩制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特剪辑。我们的团队包括帕思·沙阿、劳拉·夸雷勒、托马斯·刘和拉希克·瓦巴。特别感谢艾利什·奥尼尔提供制作支持，詹姆斯·威利茨负责工程音效，以及
Schuchnecht for her voice acting work. Our run song Hero This Week is Derek Adams. Derek and other custodial staff at NPR make it possible for us to do our jobs. Derek is helpful and solicitous and someone who takes genuine pride in his work. In recent weeks, as NPR has had to cope with the coronavirus outbreak, Derek and others have sanitized surfaces and ensure the building is equipped with soap, disinfectant and hand sanitizer. He's the very definition of an unsung hero.
卡思·舒赫内克担任配音工作。我们本周的片尾曲作者是德里克·亚当斯。德里克和NPR的其他后勤人员使我们能够顺利完成工作。德里克乐于助人、周到体贴，是一个对自己的工作怀有真正自豪感的人。最近几周，随着NPR不得不应对冠状病毒疫情，德里克和其他人一直在对表面进行消毒，并确保大楼里配备了肥皂、消毒液和手部消毒剂。他正是无名英雄的定义。
Thank you, Derek. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like today's show, please remember to share it with one friend. One last thing. This is a time of great upheaval. We want to hear the surprising, unexpected, and profound ways your life has changed since the coronavirus outbreak began. What have you noticed about your friends and family,
谢谢你，德里克。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请记得分享给一位朋友。最后一件事。这是一个充满巨变的时代。我们想听听自冠状病毒疫情爆发以来，你的人生发生的那些令人惊奇、意想不到且深远的改变。你注意到了你的朋友和家人、
about yourself, that reveal something about human nature? If you have a personal story, you will be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room, or a coat closet, and record a voice memo on your phone. Email it to us at hiddenbrainatnpr.org using the subject line human nature. Be sure to include a phone number. Again find a quiet room and record a personal experience and send it to us at hiddenbrainatnpr.org. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR.
还有你自己身上有什么，能揭示出某种人性吗？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间或衣帽间，用手机录下一条语音备忘录。发电子邮件给我们，邮箱是hiddenbrainatnpr.org，主题行请写“human nature”（人性）。请务必附上电话号码。再次提醒，找一个安静的房间，记录一段个人经历，然后发送给我们，邮箱是hiddenbrainatnpr.org。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共广播电台。
Bu videonunize iyi bakın. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.